marcus peters salty about trading by the
rams to the ravens during the 2019
season at the same time that the rams
traded for jalen ramsey with the jaguars
chris i love the fire i love the passion
i love the words that were bleeped sorry
london for the uh and manchester and the
rest of the cities in the uk and ireland
for the words that made it through but
how can you say that if you're marcus
peters because you're not on the same
level as jalen ramsey i know he needs to
think that he is but he may be the only
one who does right
i mean he's a phenomenal football player
there's no doubt about that you know
two of my favorites i love their
attitude the way they play they're
fearless you know they they live on an
island all of those type of things but
yeah what's a is it it seems like he's
taking it a little personal with jalen
ramsey i think that's where it's like
don't blame jaylen ramsey he got nothing
to do with this nothing at all he became
available through the jacksonville
jaguars and the rams yes they
disrespected marcus peters by going we
don't want to pay you because we think
we're going to trade for a guy that's an
upgrade you know so don't be mad at
jalen ramsey to do those type of things
and no as good as marcus peters is and
he's definitely one of the 10 best
corners in football there's no doubt
about it he is not jaylen ramsey jaylen
ramsey is the best corner in football
and if you don't think he's the best
corner in football you think he's the
second or third best corner in football
he does everything and he's a special
special football player and i think
that's why the rams made that that
choice there uh but i don't want to like
be negative on marcus peters he's an
awesome football player i just don't
understand that that take there
and if he's gonna be mad at anybody he
should be mad at the chiefs well that's
how you can go to that too there's two
teams that didn't want there's two teams
that got to the like precipice of wait
we have to pay this guy
now let's trade them so
i think you could also sit there and you
know and go well maybe there's some
reevaluating you need to do with your
own self there and hopefully he has done
that he's obviously found the right spot
the right place it's the perfect mesh of
his edgy character and the way he is as
a his personality and what they want him
to do on the defensive side of the ball
so he should be happy i mean he really
isn't a great spot in baltimore and
really fits what they do
and there may be a shelf life for that
kind of a personality we don't know
exactly why that's right
that's right they didn't have a jalen
ramsay to replace him with but you're
getting close to the end of the contract
you have a feeling this guy has an
overly inflated
valuation of his self his his self-worth
skills yeah and
you're going to get yourself into a
problem and maybe he had to be humbled
by being traded twice to get to the
point where he took the deal that he did
to stay with the baltimore ravens maybe
the only way marcus peters
properly reduces his
his expectations financially is to get
like the proverbial hot potato twice
traded by the chiefs traded by the rams
and oh by the way thanks to the 17th
game the rams and the ravens get
together this year so marcus peters and
jalen ramsey at some point we'll find
out next wednesday night we'll have an
opportunity to renew acquaintances and
have a conversation about which guy
really is better right well yeah
remember like when they they played two
years ago uh not long after the trade
happened and everything like that
baltimore steamrolled the rams right out
of l.a on a monday night i mean
steamrolled them and marcus peters at
one point he got an interception late in
the game
and you remember he got up and ran and
yelled jalen he yelled it you could hear
it on tv
that's what he did it caused a little
ruckus between those two i believe after
the game or anything like that but even
that that was like
a little bit of a cheap shot again jalen
ramsey wasn't the one that traded you
away or was the issue here he is the
innocent bystander i mean he he just was
upon being moved in this whole thing and
that's where i don't get it uh but but
either way you're right it's going to
add to the the rivalry or at least the
the theatrics of that game in week 17.
that game between the rams and the
ravens two years ago was the night that
lamar jackson became the mvp yes that
was that was informative that was
special yeah because it was a year after
the rams had that great monday night
game against the chiefs to see them get
shredded the way they did to the point
where i felt like watching that game
they were just broken they were just
they were right one of those i want to
go home and go to bed moments it's like
the only game i can think of out of here
yeah right it's the only game i could
think of in the mcveigh
mcvay era where i went
the rams kind of they kind of just
chalked it up and we're like we're done
we're this ain't going to be close we
can't compete we'll see you next week
it's the only game i can remember uh
where it went down like that for them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports